sohn im heutigen video soll es darum
gehen wieso ich ich würde mit euch noch
niemand von euch hat mich jemals in den
youtube trends gefunden was geglaubt und
jetzt willkommen bei anderen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es allen
gut eigentlich wollte ich heute mal
wieder einen tag pausen machen mit video
da jetzt die letzten vier tage glaube
ich jeden tag im video kamen allerdings
ist es jetzt ein sehr spontanes video
was ich eigentlich auch immer schon mal
gemacht haben wollte und das passt heute
jetzt gerade sehr gut und zwar ist das
ganze gerade wirklich sehr spontan ich
habe mir keine einzigen stichpunkte
macht oder sonst was also ich würde
einfach drauflos lagern weil es ein
thema ist das mich als youtuber ja wie
soll ich sagen schon beschäftigt weil es
mich einfach neugierig macht weil ich es
auch nicht wirklich verstehe ich bin ja
auch schon recht langen dabei ich würde
sagen ich bin jetzt bestimmt schon so
drei jahre wirklich aktiv also richtig
aktiv auf youtube was ja echt schon eine
lange zeit das ist und in der zeit hat
sich ja immer mehr verändert es gab
immer viele neue features hinzu features
wurden abgeschafft oder sonstwas und so
sieht youtube hat heute aus wie es heute
aussieht weil sich immer viel verändert
hat und deswegen sieht sich mehr so aus
wie vor drei jahren
das hatte ich irgendwo irgendwann aber
ihr wisst bestimmt was ich meine
also heute soll es um die youtube trends
gehen die ist ja auch vor drei jahren
noch nicht gab also wirklich diese
trends seite die man halt aufrufen kann
wo halt dann diese neuesten videos oder
sachen die er gerade einen trends
insofern platz 150 angezeigt werden oder
bis 49 ist als ich die seite als sie auf
kamen da war das immer richtig cool so
da wollte jeder in den youtube trend
sein weil sich auch wirklich gelohnt hat
die youtube trends des war was
besonderes wenn man da drin war und
fehler haben wir auch darauf geschaut
nur da diese trends halt zunimmt mit der
größten scheiße voll geballert werden
guckt halt keiner mehr wirklich rein so
denke ich zumindest so und im heutigen
video soll es darum gehen wie so ich
wollte mit euch noch niemand von euch
hat mich jemals in den youtube trends
gefunden es soll darum gehen warum ich
noch nie wirklich mit keinem einzigen
video in den youtube brands war
natürlich kann ich es nicht zu 100
prozent versichern warum das so ist aber
ich habe eine starke vermutung gut also
fangen wir da an das ist ja kein
geheimnis dass das dieses youtube trend
ist ganz ganz schwer zu berechnen sind
keiner kann wirklich sagen ey was muss
man machen dass man in die trends kommen
ich bin natürlich jetzt auch kein google
mitarbeitern können mich da richtig gut
aus deswegen wenn ich irgendwas nicht
weiß was wirklich von euch wissen dann
tut mir das leid
aber ja es gibt ja verschiedene theorien
wie man waren in den youtube trends
kommt erstens kann sein youtube video
macht mega viele klicks sehr viel
resonanz auf das viele sehr viele
kommentare sehr viele likes dann geht
das in die trends geballert so war das
schon öfter mal zum beispiel dann
irgendwann muss ich wieder raus dann ist
sein war ziemlich viel resonanz drunter
und das kommt dann gerne mal in die
trends andere sache könnte sein wenn man
ein video macht das wirklich aktuelles
was ein aktuelles thema betrifft zum
beispiel als in deutschland die wahlen
waren waren viele politische videos in
dem trend so danke und alex und denkt
sich so als ich dachte mir vor einem
jahr vor so einmal in den youtube trends
sein dass wir auch echt schon richtig
cool der bestimmte menge neue zuschauer
und viele klicks auf das video das
problem war irgendwie nur egal was für
ein video ich gemacht habe das hat jetzt
nicht unbedingt dann wenig aufruf oder
wenig kriegs oder so aber ich bin
wirklich nie in die grenze kommen ein
gutes beispiel von mir ist vielleicht
mal eine woche pizza video ja auch wenn
der inhalt natürlich ein bisschen
fragwürdig ist und ich so was jetzt
nicht unbedingt noch mal machen würde es
war witzig und es hat auch sehr
polarisiert und hatte nach 24 stunden
zwei hunderttausend klicks 20.000 likes
unmengen an kommentare und halt auch
drei 4000 ist das so also wirklich für
meine verhältnisse extrem viel resonanz
das video kam allerdings nicht in die
trends ein weiteres beispiel ist
vielleicht mein zeugnis video von vor
zwei oder drei wochen
was auch durch die decke ging das hat er
nach 24 stunden auch 300.000 klicks oder
so hat jetzt sogar 1,8 millionen klicks
aber auch diesmal kam das video nicht
die trends das waren jetzt zwei
beispiele es gibt noch unmengen an
weiteren beispielen von mir
es gibt auch sachen wo ich zu aktuellen
themen video gemacht habe kam auch nicht
in die trends und irgendwann habe ich
dann halt einfach aufgegeben hat mir
gesagt kommt dann bist du halt einfach
so ein youtuber der nicht in die trends
kommen ich will mich da auch eigentlich
gar nicht beschweren weil ich finde die
youtube trend sind eh nur noch müll ich
muss da gar nicht rein ich bin ja auch
längst kein kleiner youtuber mehr
allerdings jetzt meine theorie ich habe
dann irgendwann halt gedacht hey
vielleicht gibt es unterschiede zwischen
youtube an die halt in die trends kommen
und youtube an die nicht in die trends
kommen aber trotzdem wenn man eine gute
aufruf zahlen haben an dieser stelle
noch mal das beispiel mein zeugnis video
was jetzt halt 1,8 millionen klicks hat
war nicht in den trends allerdings 1,8
millionen klicks für deutschland für ein
nicht musikvideo ist schon echt
richtig gut also höher geht es nicht
unbedingt mal so schnell dieses video
war nicht in den trend es hat trotzdem
diese view zahl erreicht und das kann
ich heute meinen analytics sehen dass
das ganze nur durch empfohlen der
inhalte geschieht das heißt ihr schaut
euch gegen den video an rechts am rand
wird angezeigt oder am handy unten ja
alex wie er geht auf zeugnisse wird
anscheinend bei 1,5 millionen menschen
weit oben angezeigt und die klicken
daraus nicht in den trends einfach über
empfohlene inhalte ich habe es also so
weit gedacht was auf youtube sieht
deinen erfolg oder sage ich mal deinen
kanal letztlichen den trends sondern
unter den empfohlenen inhalt einfach
weil es im algorithmus immer so
gespeichert war
dass alex wie durch empfohlene inhalte
klicks zieht oder so also ich habe
wirklich gedacht ich bin auch sind
trends komplett raus ich werde dann ihr
einkommen
und ja das ist meine theorie ich bin
halt jemand auch ich habe gerade mit
einem freund von mir gesprochen wird per
rad schöne grüße der hat ja jetzt auch
wieder angefangen youtube videos zu
machen und hatte auch jetzt in letzter
zeit zwei drei videos die echt ziemlich
viele klicks gemacht haben für seine
verhältnisse haben wir auch nicht in die
trends sondern wahrscheinlich über diese
empfohlenen inhalte so also ich dachte
mir dann halt okay gut du bist so ein
empfohlener inhalt youtuber wie es auch
noch mehrere gibt ich kann noch weitere
namen nennen und wollte eigentlich gar
nicht mehr dieses video machen
das war dann für mich soweit gegessen
youtube trends brauche ich nicht und
jetzt habe ich heute gesehen dass mein
video von gestern nach gut eineinhalb
jahren wie es jetzt schon diese youtube
trends gibt habe ich endlich mein ziel
erreicht ich bin in den youtube trends
warum das weiß ich nicht ich kann es
euch hier mal kurz einblenden gestern
kam ein video da habe ich auch ruhig
gestellt wenn es noch nicht gesehen habt
euch auf jeden fall an einfach ein
stinknormales wie du weißt nicht viel
aufwand dahinter ich habe mich
hingesetzt habe stellt das
zusammengeschnittenen hochgeladen ist
gut angekommen hat jetzt irgendwie
gerade 100 10.000 klicks oder so acht
9000 likes 500 kommentare also nichts
was wirklich über meiner normalen
resonanz liegt also nichts besonderes es
ist auch kein aktuelles thema wunsch
gibt es auch schon seit seit einem
halben jahr nach in der leute videos zu
ja und wieso dieses video jetzt in den
trends ist das ist für mich ein
absolutes rätsel und ich kann es nicht
verstehen ich saß ebenso vom laptop habe
das gesehen und dachte wirklich hab so
zehn sekunden nichts gesagt und auch
irgendwie nichts gedacht weil ich so
erschrocken war
von also muss ich an dieser stelle
aufzugeben youtube trends wird wohl
niemand jemals in seinem ganzen leben
verstehen auch wenn ich an dieser stelle
mal sagen muss wie schade ich das finde
vor allem zum beispiel ein video von uns
was wir im sommer gedreht haben sommer
meines lebens heißt es hier mal kurz
raus wenn ihr das du nicht gesehen habe
und den sommer vermisst schaut euch auf
jeden fall laden ist in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und gleich auch am
ende aber das war wirklich ein video da
waren wir zusammen mit fünf leuten in
spanien unterwegs haben fünf tage lang
gedreht dass schneider hat auch echt
lange gedauert und wenn dann wirklich so
100 stunden arbeit in unserem video
stecken oder so gut sagen wir 40 stunden
kriegt es halt nicht diese
aufmerksamkeit wie das video gestern wo
ich vielleicht zwei oder drei stunden
insgesamt transa obwohl ich mir sicher
bin dass wenn ihr das video sehen würdet
euch ist viel besser gefallen würde als
das video von gestern zum beispiel ja
das waren meine gedanken hatte ich bin
froh dass ich das video erst mal gemacht
habe ihr könnt gerne mal eure meinung in
die kommentare schreiben was glaubt ihr
wann kommt man in die youtube trends
gibt man ganz viele daumen nach oben und
nach unten und schreibt alles voll mit
den kommentaren und ich bin mir sicher
wir kommen nicht in die trends mit
diesem video meine theorie ist zwar
immer noch so ein bisschen das ist halt
einmal youtuber gibt die durch
empfohlene inhalte groß werden und dann
halt auf youtube gibt hier auf den
trends sind und dadurch groß werden
sollen wobei man halt wirklich auch
sagen muss dass diese youtube trends
immer mehr an bedeutung verlieren ich
meine wenn ein youtube video auf platz
fünf ist der trends das macht dadurch
jetzt nicht unbedingt so die
unmenschlichen klicks wie man es
eigentlich vermuten könnte
so war es auch mal aber so ist es meiner
meinung nach nicht mehr das was mit dem
video wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich
morgen wieder
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag und
mehr haut rein absolut und schecks oder
instagram habe das ist ganz wichtig